[MUSIC].
There are over 70 million middle children
in the United States right now.
We're talking about over 70 million
Americans with both older and
younger siblings.
But, if you watch a lot of movies and
television.
And I do.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You'd think all middle children are
exactly the same.
Take for example, Jan Brady of the Brady
Bunch,
always angrily complaining about her
perfect sister, Marcia.
Or Malcolm in the Middle, who's parents
always forget to pick him up from school.
Ron Weasley,
lost in a sea of red-haired siblings,
drowning in oversized hand-me-downs.
Or sniveling Edith from Downton Abbey
[LAUGH],
always angry, coveting everything our
sisters achieve.
Again and again, middle children are
depicted as neglected ignored,
low in self-esteem, starving for
attention.
And this has to come from some basis in
reality.
After all, our country's most famous
middle child right now would have to be
Kim Kardashian, and who is more starving
for attention than her?
>> [LAUGH].
>> But, I'm a middle child and both my
parents are middle children.
So, I've always been fascinated at where
this perception of middle children
comes from.
Society hands us this view of birth order,
this spectrum.
You have dominant eldest children on one
end and
beloved youngest children on the other.
Us, middle children, are just lost
somewhere in between.
But the more I thought about it, the more
wrong I've realized that world view is.
Today, we'll start off by looking at birth
order research,
to understand where this perception of
middle children comes from.
Then, we'll separately analyze the role of
older sibling and younger sibling.
Before finally, bringing it all together
to try to define what
it means to live from the middle, whether
you have siblings or not.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So, let's start with the data.
Researchers have done a great job
explaining the characteristics of
firstborns and lastborns.
So, who here is the oldest child in their
family?
A firstborn?
Wow.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So, you guys have it made.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You will, you'll earn 1%
more income than your younger siblings and
have fewer illnesses too.
Over 60% of CEO's, Ivy League graduates
and
US Presidents are first born in their
family.
And as if this wasn't all enough.
Statistically speaking,
your parents take way more photos of you
than your younger siblings.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So, you got a great head start in the
Instagram game.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Now, who here is the youngest child in
their family, the baby?
[BLANK_AUDIO].
You guys have it pretty good too, I'd say.
You got more of lenient punishments for
the same behavior compared to your
siblings.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You are more likely to protest for more
positive social change.
And you have the highest self-esteem of
any birth order.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So congratulations, although apparently
you guys do not need the ego boost.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So, where does that leave us middles?
[BLANK_AUDIO].
A study out of Cornell talked to mothers
and
found that regardless of how many children
they have, mothers tend to turn to their
firstborn child in moments of crisis when
they need advice.
But they feel the most emotionally
connected to their youngest child.
Middle children just didn't factor in
heavily to their answer to either
question.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Professor Catherine Salmon ran a
similar series of studies.
In one, she asked undergraduates, who of
all people you know are you closest to?
What one person?
64% of firstborn children and
39% of lastborn children named a parent as
that one person.
Only 10% of middle children did.
Middle children have a fundamentally
different attachment style to their
parents.
And it's lead researchers to coin the term
Middle Child Syndrome, which refers to
the tendency of middle children to
struggle to find a role for themselves in
their family, and as a result, a role for
themselves in the world.
Middle children have the lowest
self-esteem of any birth order,
although I'd imagine having a syndrome
named after us isn't helping things.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Why do I wanna speak out on behalf of
middle children?
Because I think part of the reason Middle
Child Syndrome exists
is because it's not something we talk
about or think about.
Not part of any conversation.
I've had discussions with about a dozen
middle children in the last few weeks.
And I've been struck by how difficult it
is for us to define our role in our
family, and how it shaped us, even though
we know it did.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
It comes back to this fundamental
question.
What does it mean to live from the middle?
And I think to understand that, we first
need to understand separately, the role of
older sibling and a younger sibling,
because they are very, very different.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So, I grew up looking up to my older
brother, Josh.
He's two years older than me, and a
classic firstborn.
He's ambitious, he's driven,
he's high-achieving, responsible, a bit
neurotic.
>> [LAUGH].
>> As a short cut for
my own decision making process, I used to
just copy the things he did.
But trying to be not too Jan Brady about
it.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I tried to define myself by doing the
same things as him, but
with my own spin, differently, hopefully
better.
If he played tennis, I played tennis.
If he did highschool newspaper, I did too.
Sometimes, we even dress the same.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Having an older sibling gives you
something to prove.
Someone to emulate.
But differentiate from.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
On the other hand, being an older brother
to Brett, who's three years younger,
gave me someone to approve.
Someone to mentor.
Like many youngest children, Brett is
artistic and creative.
He is an inspiring graphic designer.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
My mom would often want me to spend more
time with Brett growing up, so
I played video games with him, never
letting him win of course.
I teach him how to use a computer program
or help him with his Math homework.
Sometimes, pretending to be annoyed, but
always so
happy that someone needed my help and was
willing to take it.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So, I think in my relationship with Josh,
my relationship with Brett and
how different they are.
And I think of this spectrum, this world
view we're given about birth order.
Ambitious Josh on one end, creative Brett
on the other,
me supposedly lost somewhere in between.
But that wasn't my experience as a middle
child.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Being a middle child isn't about being
lost between two roles.
It's about being firmly planted,
planted on both ends of the spectrum at
the same time.
To have experienced being older and
younger.
To know what it feels like to be the top
dog and the underdog.
And when you think about that perception
of being the middle child,
it unlocks amazing and unique qualities.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Middle children, from a young age,
understand though,
what it feels like to be in a role of
authority and a role of inferiority.
And because of that, research has shown
that middle children are great
negotiators, great mediators, great peace
keepers.
They're comfortable with ambiguity.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Similarly, middle children don't have the
responsibility of the first born or
the attention of the last born, so they're
free to chart their own path.
They measure high in measures of
independence.
An NYU study compared middle born CEOs to
firstborn CEOs, and
found that middle born CEOs tend to be
change makers.
They're used to setting their own
expectations so,
they're not afraid to do things
differently to experiment.
This may explain Kim Kardashian's unique
approach to business.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So you,
you may be thinking, kind of, these are
qualities we all can relate to.
And, I think you're right.
There are only 70 million middle children
in the United States, but
there's 300 million of us who are used to
living from the middle,
because that's what we're all doing.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
At business schools, we're taught to value
traits that come naturally to firstborns.
To wanna be at the head of the pack.
To report to no one.
To give a view from the top.
But life isn't business school.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We're not either first years, who have
endless questions, or second years,
who know everything.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We're somewhere in between.
We're between our board and our employees.
Between our managers and our reports.
We can be between our family and our
career.
Or our ego and our insecurity.
Instead of aspiring to make power plays,
or
step on anyone who gets in our way, we can
aspire to take root firmly in the middle.
Because being a middle means having the
humility to take advice from others, but
the confidence to know you have a voice,
that you have worth.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
A few years ago, my dad underwent an
extensive brain surgery.
It was the scariest day of my life, but in
his road to full recovery,
it brought my family closer together.
This picture was taken a few months later.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
My dad had spent a few nights in the
hospital afterwards and
preferred to not spend them alone.
So, I volunteered to camp out in the chair
next to his bed.
Napping, chatting, watching TV.
He'd ask for help getting up out of bed.
And then, a few minutes later, give me
advice,
remind me to take care of my mom the next
few weeks cuz it'd be tough on her.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
I would interrogate a doctor, on his
behalf.
Only an hour after after having my dad
proofread an email for
me that I might write my boss.
The nights were filled with these moments
where our parent-child
relationship was completely inverted, yet
somehow it felt exactly the same.
Each of us sometimes acting older,
sometimes acting younger, but
always feeling comfortable in either role.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
I think those nights at [UNKNOWN] General
Hospital with my dad at 4 a.m were two
middle children at their best.
Looking up and looking down at the very
same time.
And it's moments like these that make me
realize the view from the middle,
it's not so bad.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC].